So, you won't have any time for yourself, for shopping or anything fun before going back?
I'm planning to meet a good friend for dinner in San Francisco Friday night.
Also, I have to make time to buy some nice California wines.
Every time I come to California, I always buy good wine.
It's much cheaper here.
So, you like good wine, do you?
Have you been to Napa?
Yes, I went there last year and enjoyed tasting tours at a few wineries.
Do you know a lot about wine?
Actually, Victoria knows quite a bit about wine.
That's true.
I love wine more than just about anything else!
One of my friends owns a small winery in Carmel.
I help out there sometimes.
When you come back next, I would like to invite you to a tour there.
Thanks, that sounds great.
I'd better start planning that next business trip after all.